there's an old saying in Tennessee I
know it's in Texas probably in Tennessee
this does fool me once shame on shame on
you
if boom you can't get fool again the
realm do you know what the realm is it's
the thousand blades of Aegon's enemies a
story we agreed to tell each other over
and over till we forget that it's a lie
what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back for another Game of Thrones Season
eight prediction video today I want to
talk about Cersei Lannister and whether
or not she is actually pregnant the
seven season a Game of Thrones is over
and Cersei definitely appears to be on
her way of becoming the mad queen now
that Jaime has abandoned her as the
queen of the Seven Kingdoms Cersei has
pretty much only had one thing on her
mind which is destroying all of her
enemies but lately Cersei has had
something else on her mind because she
is claiming to be pregnant Game of
Thrones Season seven was full of
revelations but I think this one really
caught people off guard for the simple
fact that we were led to believe
Cersei could no longer have any children
the main reason why this was so
surprising was because of the prophecy
Cersei was told by the woods waits known
as Maggie the frog in a flashback
sequence in the season 5 premiere we saw
a young Cersei Lannister having her
future told to her by Maggy the Frog
well the King and I have children the
king will have 20 children
you will have three that doesn't make
sense
gold will be their crowns cold rounds so
far Maggie has been a hundred percent
correct King Robert Baratheon did have
multiple illegitimate children without
the help of Cersei while Cersei only had
three Joffrey Marcella and Tommen all
three of whom have died
Joffrey and Marcella were both poisoned
then Tommen commits suicide by throwing
himself out of the window after he sees
that Cersei has murdered his wife
Margaery Tyrell
now that Cersei is pregnant a fourth
child would contradict the prophecy
which has a lot of people believing that
she will either die before her child is
born miscarry or that she's not even
pregnant at all since Maggie the frog
has been correct so far this leads me to
believe that Cersei is either lying or
something will happen to her or her baby
before she has the chance to give birth
I think both of these possibilities are
likely we all know Cersei has never had
a problem with lying if she knows it
will benefit her in some way and the
chances of Cersei living long enough to
have this child seem pretty slim
considering almost all of the other main
characters want her dead but first you
have to ask yourself why would Cersei
lie about something like this does she
have a good enough reason to do this
well it would be a great way to ensure
her safety to a certain extent even
though Tyrion Lannister is Daenerys
Targaryen saying to the Queen Cersei
knows Tyrion has always loved her
children and by saying she's pregnant
she could see this as a way to buy
herself some more time
Cersei knew that she had to wait for
Euron to return with the golden company
so by hinting at her pregnancy with
Tyrion she would know he would try to
prevent something from happening to
Cersei at this time at least until she
had the baby and by then your own would
be back with the reinforcements also
when Cersei and Tyrion were talking
privately Cersei lowers her hand to
cover her belly and according to the
producers that move was deliberate I
don't care about taking my worst
impulses I don't care about making world
a better place and the world
it's a little bit of a pokey and they're
playing there because it seems like
she's bluffing and he reads her Bluff
but she wanted him to read her bluff
this was all part of her game you're
pregnant sir she's become quite good at
playing this game she wasn't in power
but she was on the edges of power and
she learned how to operate in that
environment and she placed here him
pretty beautifully
Circe Juana Tyrion to know that she was
pregnant because she wanted a reason to
appear to have changed her mind about
supporting Dani and John's mission that
way they would not see the betrayal
coming later
but if Cersei is willing to use the idea
that she's pregnant to manipulate Tyrion
is it then crazy to say she might be
faking the entire thing especially since
Cersei claims that Jaime is the dumbest
Lannister she did say he would fall for
anything
so does that include a fake pregnancy by
his sister lover you also have to keep
in mind when Cersei was talking to
Tyrion she did say as soon as she laid
eyes on the white all she could think
about was protecting the ones that she
loved she said she did not care about
being a good ruler or restoring the
realm or anything like that all she
cared about was their child because she
did have her hand on her belly as she
was saying this but when that white came
charging at Cersei she doesn't try to
protect her baby the only time she puts
her hand over her stomach is when she is
in front of Tyrion or Jaime which is
always behind closed doors now the
reason why she might have lied to Jaime
about this is because Cersei needed
Jaime he was the commander of her armies
and he was always extremely loyal to
Cersei she knew that if Jaime left then
it would not be long before others might
follow him and abandon Cersei as well by
telling Jaime she is pregnant she could
have assumed he would stay with her
until the very end
also Cersei could have been setting up
this lie very early just in case she
would lose the war and end up getting
captured do you think John or Daenerys
would be the type of person to execute a
pregnant woman probably not it also
seemed like it might have been perfect
timing for Cersei to manipulate Jamie
into sticking by her side considering
she broke the news to him right after
Daenerys torched his army and nearly
killed him
Jaime did tell Cersei they had no way to
stop Daenerys dragons so Cersei might
have started to feel like Jaime was
ready to wave the white flag so she gave
him a new reason to fight knowing you
have a baby on the way would certainly
be enough motivation to keep fighting
for survival these are just some of the
reasons why she might be lying but it
doesn't mean I'm actually saying this is
what happened but it is possible now on
the other hand she could actually be
pregnant Cersei and Jaime did recently
have sex with each other shortly before
she revealed that she was pregnant
Jaime has gotten her pride
three times before so it's certainly not
out of the realm of possibility that he
could do this again also we did see
Cersei and Qyburn talking privately just
as Jaime walks into the room to talk
with Cersei Qyburn exits right after he
told Cersei he can give her some sort of
medicine I'm not exactly sure what kind
of medicine he was referring to but it
could have something to do with morning
sickness or maybe even something to get
rid of the baby
whatever it was Cersei declined his
offer but then again Cersei and Qyburn
could have set this up the foal Jaime
and us as the viewers Qyburn is Circe's
little servant so i won't rule this out
as being a staged meeting either we also
have to keep something else in mind
the older Cersei gets the less likely
she is able to get pregnant now another
our woman her age that have kids all the
time but it does get harder the older
you get even lady Alanna had concerns
about how fertile Cersei may be if the
rumors about my children were true then
Joffrey is no king at all and house
Tyrell is throwing its prized flower
into the dirt and if ceci is too old to
give Loras children we are throwing
another prized flower into the dirt it
is a chance we simply cannot take at the
end of the day it might not matter
whether Cersei is lying or not because
she probably won't survive long enough
to see the child be born anyway her
brother Jaime has already abandoned her
and there's no telling how many men
Jaime might be able to get to rally
behind him before he makes it all the
way north
now that Cersei has admitted to Jaime
she lied about helping Jon and Daenerys
in this new war for the dawn it's
probably only a matter of time before
Jaime reveals this information to Tyrion
Brienne or John and Danny themselves as
soon as they find out Cersei left them
hanging in their most desperate time of
need they're gonna have no other reason
to want to make any further negotiations
with her Cersei has now proven she will
lie right to their faces so they have to
assume she will do that again then when
you combine this with Dany and brains
visions of the throne room it doesn't
look like the current Queen will
continue to roll much longer if Cersei
doesn't die by Danny's dragon fire then
someone will most like
wrap their hands around Circe's pale
white throat and choke the life from her
there are more than enough reasons why
Cersei should die next season
Shaun's a once her dead arya once her
dead and many other people I would be
shocked if she made it out of the series
alive however in my opinion I do believe
Cersei is pregnant she does have reasons
to lie about it but I don't think that
she is but like I said at the end of the
day I believe Maggie the frogs prophecy
will remain true one way or another
Cersei will not have this baby the witch
told me years ago she promised me three
children she promised me they'd die and
gold their shrouds everything she said
came true you couldn't have stopped it
his prophecy you don't believe that of
course I do you told me yourself my
father died
Cersei was actually supposed to miscarry
during season seven already the entire
plot was leaked last season and the leak
ended up being 99.9% accurate the only
thing from the lake that did not happen
was Circe's miscarriage at the end of
the season seven finale in Circe's last
seen they were gonna have her wake up in
a bed of blood but for whatever reason
they cut that scene out of the finale
I personally believe they are saving it
to kick off season eight that way Cersei
spirals even further out of control over
the course of the entire final season
but we shall see how they do this now I
know some of you may be thinking how is
Maggie the frogs prophecy true if Cersei
really had another child with Robert
back in season one Cersei references
this child and many people believe in my
big injury in my opinion the show
invented those scenes to make Cersei
look a little bit more sympathetic in
those moments
Cersei does get pregnant by Robert in
the books but she immediately has an
abortion by drinking moon tea she admits
this during a conversation with Ned
Stark as we all know Cersei hated Robert
and she would have done anything in her
power to prevent herself from having his
child because she did grow to despise
him
I don't believe Gentry is Cersei son but
if you do then that is fine by me I tend
to believe maggy's prophecy Cersei will
only give birth to three children which
means if Cersei is really pregnant now
then something will have
before that baby ever sees the light of
day let me know what you think about
Circe's pregnancy do you believe her or
is she making this up and also let me
know what you think will happen to the
baby if you do think she's pregnant
anyways thank you all very much for
watching the video I appreciate that as
always and I also want to give a big
shout out to everyone on patreon you've
helped support the channel for another
month and I cannot thank you all enough
I hope everyone has a great day I will
see you again soon bye
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you